The dark secret of ICT is that while
it's the most popular trading strategy
out there, barely anyone trades it
profitably. Why? Because they're missing
one thing that all ICT gurus leave out.
Once I figured out what it was and built
my own strategy with ICT concepts, I
broke the world record prop firm payout
making two and a half million dollars in
a single payout. By the end of this
video, you'll know what the missing
piece is, how to use it, and how to stop
blowing up your account like most ICT
traders do. Let me start with the real
foundation of what ICT actually is
because most traders get this completely
wrong. Now, when we're talking about ICT
and trading in general, it really is
just two things. We have liquidity and
order flow. Now, what do those actually
mean? Now, liquidity, simply put, are
all the participants that are operating
in the market. So, everyone else in the
market. Now, that includes retail
traders, it includes hedge funds, prop
firms, real legitimate prop firms,
institutional players, banks, you know,
other entities. So, essentially,
everyone that's participating in the
market adds to liquidity. Now, each one
of those participants has orders in the
marketplace, whether that's a market
order or a pending order. Now, all those
pending orders are adding to the
liquidity pool. That might be stop
orders or limit orders, and those sit
above highs and below old lows. So,
whenever we get an old high or an old
low, right, we're going to have stop
losses that sit above these old highs
and below the old lows, and all of that
is considered liquidity. Essentially, if
you are participating in the market, you
are adding to liquidity. So, when we
look at a chart and we see old highs and
old lows, all we're trying to determine
is where are those participants' orders,
right? Where is every one of those
entities' stop loss and where is their
take profit? And where is the market
really trying to go? So, when we're
placing our own stop orders, we're
trying to place our stop loss in a
logical area where other participants
might have their stop loss, and we're
trying to target liquidity pools, we're
trying to anticipate where the market is
trying to reach to for a target, where
they can then use liquidity to exit
their trade. Now, the next piece is
going to be order flow. Where is the
market actually trying to go in this
given moment and in this specific market
condition? I try not to overthink these
things, you know, the inner workings of
liquidity and order flow. All I really
care about is where is there liquidity
resting and which direction is the
market trying to go. You can dive down a
very deep rabbit hole and you might not
get anywhere by trying to educate
yourself more on liquidity or more on
order flow. At the end of the day, the
markets can be very random and we're
just trying to participate in the
direction that the overall market
towards. Now, here's the wild part.
Traders who actually understand both of
these concepts, who actually get it, can
still blow up and most of them do. But,
the reason has nothing to do with the
actual system. And why is that? It's not
the system, it's you. So, there's a
couple different patterns that I see
many, many traders fall victim to and
I'm not talking about professional
traders, I'm talking about retail
traders that are trying to become
professional. Number one is system
hopping. They're jumping from strategy
to strategy chasing something that wins
more than 70% of the time and that
honestly just does not exist and you
don't need it to exist either. You need
to find something that works 50, 60% of
the time and just continue trading
through it. So, the biggest problem is
that a lot of traders just get bored of
trading the same system over and over
and over again. And if you can relate to
this, you know exactly what I'm talking
about. You think that trading has to be
this massively complex thing like rocket
science and it causes you to just
constantly be in this state of education
where you're just trying to learn new
things and try and implement new things
over and over and over again. But, the
problem with that is every time you pick
up a new system, it resets the learning
curve. So, let's say you've been trading
a system for 3 months, you get tired of
it and then start all over again, right?
Because it's maybe not giving you the
results that you want and you have to
reset the learning curve again, right?
When you pick up a new system, you have
to back test it, you have to forward
test it, you have to learn its nuances
and it's just non-stop. So, all you have
to do is find something that resonates
with you and just stick with it. I know
it's going to be difficult, but that's
the part of trading that most traders
never get to. Pattern number two, why
most people can't make this work, is
that they cannot sit through losses.
Just like I mentioned, you're not going
to find something that wins 70% of the
time. Let's say if your your trading
system works 50% of the time, 60% of the
time even. You're going to go through a
period of losing trades. It might be
four, five, six, seven, maybe even up to
10 losing trades in a row. And what
happens? You lose faith in the system,
and then you try and find something
different because you think it's stopped
working. But that really is just
variance, okay? Part of the market is
variance. You're going to have losing
streaks, it's just part of the job. And
that mostly stems from you not
respecting the probabilities of each
specific trade. At some point you're
going to go through this period where it
feels like your system just stops
working. And that's occurred to me
pretty much every single year since I've
been trading full-time now for the past
5 years or so. But where the
professional differentiates himself from
the retail trader or the amateur trader,
is that when they go on a losing streak,
they don't change anything. They
continue trading the same system because
they know at some point the market
conditions are going to turn and their
edge is going to start working again.
And that's just part of variance. You
have to be able to sit through the
losses, you have to be able to trade
through those rough periods even when
your system's not working, and you have
to stick with it, right? You cannot
panic when that drawdown comes because
it it's going to come. You're going to
go through a drawdown period, and it's
going to feel like you need to find a
new system. But I beg you, stick with
it. Okay, pattern number three, it's a
causation of patterns number two and
one. As you abandon the edge, you find
something that works even if it's just
50% of the time and it's paying you
well, if you go through a losing streak
or if you go through a period where you
feel like you can add more complexity or
more filters or more this or more that
to your system, you're going to find out
that you abandon that edge. You have an
edge, you have something that's
repeatable, you might get bored of it
and you might try and add something to
it. You might want to add some more
flair to it, right? You're going to
start studying volume profile or order
flow or trend lines or whatever. You
want to start adding indicators to your
chart. When really, the professional
traders find a couple tools and they
just stick with them through thick and
thin. Right? You find something that
actually works, you hit a rough patch,
and then you quit before ever seeing it
through different market conditions.
Now, when I talk about market
conditions, a lot of people don't
realize that 3 to 6 months, or even 9
months, or 12 months is not really
enough of a sample size to say that
you've traded different market
conditions. So, just as an example,
let's go back to COVID 2020 when the Fed
was only cutting interest rates. You
know, that lasted probably 12 months.
And what happened at the end of it? So
many traders just got used to one
regime, which was interest rate cuts.
And that lasted for, you know, upwards
of 12 months where they were only
cutting rates. And what happened when
they stopped cutting rates? A lot of
those traders, they didn't know how to
trade when the market conditions
changed. So, I don't want you to abandon
an edge within 3 to 6 months, or even 12
months. That to me is not a full market
cycle. You have to stick with something
for multiple years to even determine if
it's profitable or not because you have
to be able to see if it survives in any
market condition. You can't just make
that judgment based off of one market
condition. Now, the most important part
with all of this is that every single
trading concept has a failure rate. And
some of them are way higher than you'd
even expect. So, let me show you. Now,
I'm just using these as an example, but
as far as ICT goes, there are many
different concepts. You know, you don't
really know where to start and you're
trying to trade all of them all at the
same time. And without you journaling,
you're not really going to know what
works and what doesn't. Now, what
happened to me was I was pretty much
trading all of the ICT concepts that I
could. I was trading fair value gaps,
liquidity raids, breakers, order blocks,
OTE, without realizing that each one of
those setups and signals has its own win
rate. It has a stand-alone win rate and
statistic behind it. And when I looked
at my journal, you know, I would kind of
look at the overall statistics. I would
look at my win rate, I'll look at my
risk to reward, and what I didn't really
realize was that, you know, maybe on 70%
of my fair value gap trades, I was
making money. But then on 20% of the
liquidity raids, I was making money. And
maybe on 25% of the breakers, I was
making money. And 35% of the order
blocks, I was making money. Meaning,
when I looked at my overall statistics,
I was actually losing money because I
was trading all of these different
concepts. When When I had that
realization, when I saw fair value gaps
making me 65 to 70% of the money that I
was making, I abandoned the rest of
these. Like, I stopped trading the rest
of them because I realized that this
setup is not this setup, okay? And it
has a different win rate and statistics
behind it. So, let's say if you're
trading fair value gaps and you go on a
really big win streak. But then you
start trading liquidity raids. Now, all
of a sudden, your win rate is going to
be affected by that, okay? And your
system and your overall stats are going
to be affected by that. So, let's say if
I'm losing on 80% of the trades that I
take that's a liquidity raid or turtle
soup, that's really dragging down my
statistics. And when I looked at my
overall win rate per setup, right? I was
going in and tagging my journal with a
fair value gap or liquidity raid.
Sometimes it would look like I was going
on losing streaks, but you know, the
last four or five out of five fair value
gaps that I traded were winners, right?
So, maybe at some point in time in a
specific month, I was five out of five,
meaning 100% win rate with fair value
gaps. And then maybe I was a two of
seven with liquidity raids. So, what did
that lead me to do? It led me to stop
trading liquidity raids entirely. Now,
the importance of focusing on just one
of these is because even just trading
one of these is going to take you a
really long time to understand the
nuances behind it. Just think about each
one of these concepts as it's own thing,
just like as if it's it's own system,
okay? So, if you're very comfortable
trading fair value gaps and you've never
traded liquidity raids or breakers
before, well, you're basically starting
all over again from scratch. You have to
build a sample size trading liquidity
raids, trading breakers. And if you
don't want to do that and if you found
something that works for you 60-70% of
the time, just stick with it and be okay
with that. And you can become a
professional trader just with one or two
concepts. Now, how did I take this data
and improve upon them, right? Cuz at
certain points, I just got so
comfortable with fair value gaps that I
could basically trade them blind. I knew
what I was looking for as far as bias
and context, and I was trading these,
and it was basically autopilot. You
know, almost seven out of 10 fair value
gap trades that I took were profitable.
But now I wanted to add something
because let's say I didn't get enough
setups, and I wanted to add more to my
system. Let's say I didn't get enough
setups because maybe I only had one or
two really great fair value gap setups
within a specific week, but I was
noticing other setups, right? I was
noticing liquidity raids. I was noticing
breakers. I was noticing order blocks.
Well, those win rates weren't really
that great. So, what I had to do was I
had to take each one of these setups
individually and work on them and refine
them and understand when to trade them
and when not to trade them. But
originally, before I became profitable,
right? This is how I became profitable.
I saw that fair value gaps were the only
setup that I was profitable with, and I
scratched the rest of these, okay? But
when I was a full-time trader and I
wanted to add new things to give me a
different look on the markets and be
able to be more active in the markets,
then I started adding back in these
concepts and started refining them and
improving their win rates and
understanding the nuances behind them.
But you as a beginning trader should
just be focusing on one to two trade
setups. That's it. Nothing else. So,
which two should you actually pick? Now,
I took the top two right off the chart
and I built my entire system off them.
And I'm going to show you what that
looks like. So, the top two ones that I
picked were the swing failure pattern or
liquidity raid, and I'm going to get
into that in just a second. So, that's
when price runs a higher low, it grabs
the stops, and then it closes back
inside the range. The close back inside
of the range is the market telling you
that the move failed. And essentially,
it's showing you that traders are
trapped now on the other side of the
trade. Okay, that's my trigger. The
entry, however, I started using as the
fair value gap. So, once I got the
trigger, then I have a fair value gap as
my lower time frame entry. Now, I want
to make something very clear, and this
is something that I've had discussions
with my group over the last couple
weeks. How do you find the right trigger
and what time frames do you use? Because
when I first started trading, I would
just sit down at the charts and just
flip through different time frames. Just
incessantly flipping through time
frames. And I would find setups on every
time frame and not really have a process
of going top-down. So, now what do I do?
I start on the higher time frame and I
wait for a trigger. If I don't find the
trigger on the higher time frame, I do
not drop down to the lower time frame.
That's mistake number one. So, if you
don't have a trigger on a higher time
frame, that higher time frame could be
the 15-minute, the 1-hour, the 4-hour,
the daily. It doesn't really matter. If
you do not have on the higher time
frame, then you don't have a trade. Do
not try and drop down to the lower time
frames and force something because
you're going to put yourself into very
bad trades where there's really no
context behind it. Okay, so on the
higher time frame, in this case, we're
going to use a 1-hour example, I'm
waiting for a trigger. And a trigger
only occurs on the closure of a candle.
If I don't get a closure, then I don't
have a trigger. Okay, how many of you
watching this video have seen a possible
trigger, right? You enter the trade and
then by the top of the hour, right? That
higher time frame candle prints, the
trigger's no longer there. Right?
Because you're not waiting for the
closure. The closure is going to tell
you if it's a trigger or not, right?
You've probably seen bullish setups turn
bearish by the end of the hour and then
all of a sudden you're in a terrible
trade and you're like, why did I even
enter this? If I just waited for the
higher time frame to give me the
confirmation before dropping down into
the lower time frame, you're going to
save yourself a lot of headache. Okay,
the fair value gap entry, it's the
imbalance left behind when price moves
extremely fast and it almost always
comes back to fill it. That's your entry
in the direction of the SFP that you
get. So, the SFP, again, swing failure
pattern or liquidity raid. So, how does
this trade actually play out? First of
all, you're going to find the liquidity.
So, you want to mark your obvious highs
or your lows on the higher time frame.
Now, that's where everybody stops or
targets are going to be sitting. Step
number two, you're going to wait for
price to run past it. You do not want to
anticipate, you want to just react.
Because I'm going to show you in a
second. When I first started trading
liquidity raids, why was my win rate so
low, right? The way that ICT taught
liquidity raids or turtle soups was as
it's trading above an old high, you want
to short into that, right? So, I would
short into it, not really know where to
put my stop loss. It would stop me out
and then turn around. Okay, so my
anticipation of it turning around was
the reason I was taking losses, and
which is a reason why my win rate was so
low. So, when I started diving into it,
I said, "Why don't I wait for another
confirmation?" And that's a closure back
above an old low, right, for a bullish
swing failure pattern, or a closure
below the old high as a bearish swing
failure pattern, right? Again,
confirmation of the failure. We want
confirmation of the failure, meaning a
closure back inside the range. That's
your SFP. Step number four is you're
going to enter on the fair value gap on
the lower time frame. Okay? Not until
you do these three steps do you enter
the lower time frame. So, you're not
looking for fair value gaps until you
have the higher time frame confirmation.
Now, let's get into some of the
examples, right? So, let's go over the
bullish swing failure pattern, all
right? I want you guys to pay close
attention to this. What is actually a
swing point, right? The swing point is
when we get a low, a lower low, and then
a higher low. That creates a swing
point. So, we have this old swing point,
right? Notice how price trades through
the low and then closes back above it.
As soon as we get the closure back above
it, and I'm talking about a strong
closure, I don't mean closing just a
little bit above it, and this closing as
a bearish candle. We really want to see
a long wick, or we want to see it close
bullish, actually. So, the stronger the
candle, the better. If this actually
closed bullish, it would be a much
stronger signal to go long. But, we're
not trading this specific hourly candle
until we get the closure. Because until
this hourly candle closes, you don't
know if it's going to close as a swing
failure pattern. What happens if this
hourly candle traded lower than closed
through the low? Well, guess what? You
don't have a swing failure pattern,
right? You just tried to anticipate a
swing failure pattern. So, again, as
we're taking out the low, you might have
40 minutes to go before you get a
confirmation that this is an actual
swing failure pattern. What do I
recommend? You have to wait the 40
minutes out because you don't know if
this is going to actually going to close
as a swing failure pattern. But, let's
say if the bias is bullish, we get a
bullish swing failure. This is telling
us that anybody that tried to get short
is now trapped in the short. And our
next logical direction is higher. All
right, so this is the liquidity aspect.
Order flow is when the market starts
trading in the opposite direction and
starts trading towards the targets. Now,
let's go over a bearish example, which
in my opinion, this is a much stronger
example because we have this old swing
high up here, right? So, we have a high,
a higher high, and a lower high. Again,
this is all on the hourly time frame.
What do we get here? We get a swing
failure pattern. And again, we have to
wait for the closure. But, what does the
closure tell us? This is a very strong
closure compared to the previous one.
It's showing us that the market actually
closed bearish on this hour. It took out
the previous high and rejected the high.
And you can see how strong this reaction
is after we get confirmation. Again, as
this hourly candle open up, you can
imagine what this looked like. Okay, the
hour probably opened up here and it
started trading higher right away. And
at the time, it looked very, very
bullish, right? But, what we're we're
looking for is a trigger on this higher
time frame. Again, this is the hourly
time frame. This is on June 9th of 2026
on the Nasdaq. You guys can go back and
study this. But, as this market's
trading higher on this hour, right,
we're not touching it, right? We're
waiting to see what happens at this old
swing high. Now, if we close through the
swing high, then obviously we don't have
a setup because we don't have a swing
failure pattern. All right, and we don't
even have a bullish swing failure
pattern. All right, if you're looking
for a bullish swing failure pattern to
get long, we need to see an old low be
taken out first. All right, so here, if
it did close bullish, we wouldn't have a
trade in either direction. But, because
of the fact that it did close bearish,
again, we took out the previous high, it
closed bearish, we have a very nice
closure. It closed near the low. Then
and only then do you drop down to the
lower time frame to find an entry in one
of these two or three hourly candles.
All right, let's get into the lower time
frame entries. All right, this is our
bullish SFP. Remember, we had our hourly
SFP. So, we had this old swing low and
we closed through it. Inside of this
next hour, we're looking for fair value
gap entries. Okay, so we plot out our
fair value gaps. You can even use
inverted fair fair gaps. Again, that
requires a whole different set of data
and statistics behind it. Learn what
type of setup you're comfortable with
and understand that once you enter that
trade, again, the market can be very
random. You have to understand the
statistics behind each one of your
setups so you can have confidence in
holding them and trading them properly.
Right? So, after we get that SFP, we
have a 5-minute fair value gap. Let's
say if you were to enter on this fair
value gap, right? Your stop should go
below candle two of the fair value gap.
Then you have to be able to sit through
all of this sideways price action. Look
at what it does. It rallies higher and
then presents another fair value gap,
right? It retraces. You have to be able
to sit through all of this because you
don't know if it's going to reach your
target right away. There's no guarantee
that it's going to do that. You have to
be comfortable with all of the outcomes,
all of the uncertain outcomes. But
knowing that you put your stop loss in a
logical place, you should be comfortable
if it does go to your stop loss, at
least you're protecting your account
capital. Now, these setups do not work
100% of the time. You're going to lose
on a lot of trades and if you want to
become a professional trader, that's
something you have to become comfortable
with. Losing on trades and repeating the
same process day in day out, week in
week out. You can see eventually this
trade makes its way all the way to
target three. Now, if you go back and
look at the hourly chart that I shared,
it eventually did, but you have to be
able to sit through all of this. You
have to be able to hold overnight if
possible or you have to be able to close
your trades ahead of that closing window
for futures prop firms, you have to be
able to close and reopen and adjust your
risk accordingly. Now, here's the
bearish example. We have that hourly
swing failure pattern and then we get
our first fair value gap that appears
after we get the closure back below
inside of the range. We enter on the
touch of a fair value gap and then this
one eventually pays out a 6:1. Knowing
this and actually trading it
consistently two completely different
things. It took me 14 years, blown
accounts, and thousands of hours of
screen time before this stuff finally
clicked. You don't have to figure it out
alone like I did. That's why I built the
Trading Apprentice where I personally
walk traders through this exact
framework, the swing failure pattern,
the fair value gap, the bias, the risk
model, the stuff most YouTubers won't
actually show you. And the traders
inside are at every stage. Take Zo for
example, he just got his first couple of
payouts. Leon just pulled a $10,000
payout. The guy's stacking. And C got a
$52,000 payout. That's a full-time
income off of a couple trades. I'll
leave a link to apply down in the
description, but I want to be clear, I
don't work with just anyone. If the link
still works, there are slots left,
otherwise you can join the wait list. As
always, don't forget to like and
subscribe, and I'll see you guys in the
next one.